For me, it means to bring a different perspective...
...and empower women in business.
For me, to be a woman in business,...
...it means to enter spaces where you can make change...
...whether that be big or small...
...and just know by being there and raising your voice,...
...you're playing a key role in breaking those inequitable systems.
And it also means stepping into your own personal power...
...in creating space for others...
...who come from marginalized communities to do the same.
For me, being a woman in business is leading with the example,...
...trying my best no matter the scenario...
...and always learning and improving.
Being a really good role model...
...and showing other women what they are capable of.
I've been really lucky to have great mentors in my life...
...and so I want to pay it forward...
...and make sure I can empower other women in positions in the future.